الرئيس الاوكراني في موقف لا يحسد عليه
وضغوطات غربيه للاطاحه
يشعرون بالفرح واشنطن توقف مساعداتها
مجددا خطتكم غير قابله للتنفيذ على ارض
الواقع استيقظوا من احلامكم الورديه هكذا
ردت موسكو على الغرب وبوتين يكشف عن احد
اسرار قوه روسيا وبيلاروسيا تدعو الى
طاوله السلام اوكرانيا تكثف جهودها وتتحرك
على خط المواجهه الخارجيه الروسيه تعلن
كيف تسبب الاوكران بالحرب على انفسهم ما
الذي حصل القوات الاوكرانيه تراقب هدفا
جديدا يقترب تحقيقه والجيش الروسي يحرج
الغرب ويستفيد من اخطائه الكيان
الاسرائيلي يجتاز الحرمات الفلسطينيه
والسعوديه ترد وفيتنام تتلاعب باعصاب
التنين الصيني
واشنطن تخلف وعدها من روسيا الى اوكرانيا
يتحول الضغط الغربي ليلقي الغرب بثقله على
الكاهن الاوكراني فهي صحيفه واشنطن ان
مسؤولين غربيين يمارسون ضغوطا على
اوكرانيا من اجل اجراء انتخابات رغم الحرب
هذه الانتخابات الاستبدال الرئيسكي
والاعضاء النيابيين
ليس ذلك فقط فهنا الامريكانو يتراجعون عن
دعم الوعد به اوكرانيا حيث لن يتجاوز كسر
واشنطن لبعضها ثلاثه ايام فقط
بان رئيس مجلس النواب كيفن تراجع عن قراره
السابق بسحب مبلغ 3000 مليون دولار الذي
وعد به لتدريب عسكريين اوكرانيين لننتقل
الى سبل المفاوضات والسلام حيث قال وزير
الخارجيه الروسيس ان الدول تدرك جيدا ان
خطه الرئيس الاوكراني
غير قابله للتنفيذ لكن هذه الدول لا تزال
تؤكد انها الاساس الوحيد للمفاوضات وعلى
ذات السياق صرح وزير الخارجيه
البيلاروسيسرج بان ميسك ستبذل قصار جودها
لحل النزاع في اوكرانيا مضفا من الواضح ان
من خلال زياده امدادات الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا فان الغرب مصمم على مواصله الحرب
حتى اخر اوكراني لكن السؤال المهم هو هل
تريد اوكرانيا ذلك هل يحتاج الاوكرانيون
الى حرب السنزاف من جانبنا نحن مقتنعون
بانها لا تريد ذلك سنترك اجابات الاسئله
لكم متابعينا ونكمل لنعد الى وزير
الخارجيه الروسي الذي تحدث عن سبب الحرب
في اوكرانيا موضحا ان وحده اراضي اوكرانيا
انتهكت اولئك الذين نفذوا ودعموا الانقلاب
حين اعلنوا الحرب على الدومبس والقرم
وقصفوا شعبهم واكد ان موسكو اعترفت بسياده
اوكرانيا على اساس اعلان استقلالها عام
1991 فيما تحدث الرئيس الروسي
عن اقوى سلاح لروسيا مؤكدا ان الشعب مصدر
القوه في روسيا ومشيرا الى ان الشعب نفسه
هو من يحدد مساره تطورها وشدد بوتين على
الجداره الكبيره التي تتمتع بها اللجنه
المركزيه في التنفيذ الفعال لاهم حق
دستوري للمواطنين والمتمثل في الانتخاب
والترشح في الميدان كثفت القوات
الاوكرانيه تحركاتها على خط المواجهات في
كوبي عسكا وهي مدينه تقع في مقاطعه خاركيف
بشمال شرق اوكرانيا ذكرت مصادر اعلاميه
اوكرانيه ان قوات اللواء 62 الاوكراني
اجرى التدريبات على اطلاق النار خلف
وتاتي هذه التحركات في اطار هجوم مضاد
يشنه الجيش الاوكراني على القوات الروسيه
وخلال هجوم مضاد لاستعاده اراضيها افاد
مسؤول اوكراني ان الاختراق الكبير للهجوم
المضاد يتمثل باستعاده مدينه
عن خط الجبهه ما يسمح للقوات الاوكرانيه
بالتقدم باتجاه مينيتوبول وشبه جزيره
القرم وهدف ثمين يسيل له لعاب الاوكران
لكن هل هناك امكانيه لتحقيق حاليا تجيب
القوات الاوكرانيه باعلانها اختراق خطوط
القوات الروسيه في جنوب اوكرانيا وبحسب
مسؤولين فقد نجح الاختراق الاوكراني في
استعاده مدينه توكماك ليقترب الاوكرانيون
اكثر من شبه جزيره القرم التي سيطرت عليها
روسيا سابقا اليكم المصدر يتحدث الجانب
الاوكراني عن قرب اكبر الخطوط الدفاعيه
الروسيه في الجهه الجنوبيه وتحديدا في
محور تابريا الذي يقول قائد هذا المحور
بان القوات الروسيه تتكبد خسائر كبيره حيث
اكد بان القوات الاوكرانيه تمضي قدم في
المقابل للافاده وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بصد
هجمات اوكرانيه جديده على عده محاور
للقتال وتحيد نحو 500 وستين عسكريا للعدو
واسقاط مروحيه وخمسه عشره مسيره خلال 24
ساعه وها نحن نتصفح المصدر كما تشاهدونه
امامكم في الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه
بينما كان الجيش الاوكراني قد افاد بان
قوته خاضت 20 اشتباكا مع قوات روسيه على
جبهات القتال كافه خلال اليوم واضاف الجيش
في بيان انه صد هجمات روسيه في مارينكا
وشختار باقليم دومباس شرقي البلاد اما
فيعترفون بقوه الدب الروسي مجددا حيث ذكرت
صحيفه بولس للجرنا الجيش الروسي استفاد من
اخطائه العسكريه في الاسابيع الاولى من
الحرب مع اوكرانيا وبتي يسعى الان لتحقيق
اهدافه باقل الخسائر من جهه ثانيه
ربما تكون عاجزه عن توفير مليون قذيفه
للجيش الاوكراني خلال العام الحالي يا لها
من صدمات توجه لاوكرانيا من الغرب الواحده
تلو الاخرى لكن لا تلتفت لهذه الضربات
الغربيه بل ولا ياخذ الاوكران حذرهم ايضا
من التحذيرات الروسيه حيث وصلت سفينه قمح
اوكراني ثانيه الى اسطنبول عبر البحر
الاسود وذلك رغم تهديدات موسكو بضرب اي
سفر تنطلق من هذا البلد او تتوجه اليه
فكيف سترد موسكو الاحداث والتطورات
افادت دائره الاوقاف الاسلاميه في القدس
بان اكثر من 500 مستوطن اقتحم المسجد
الاقصى ياتي هذا في الوقت الذي حضرت فيه
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه والفصائل من استمرار
الدعوات المتطرفين اليهود لاقتحام المسجد
الاقصى وشددت على ان ذلك سيؤدي الى تصاعد
العنف الا فيتنام تجري اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن محادثه مع فيتنام بشان
اتفاق لاضخم عمليه نقل اسلحه في التاريخ
بين الخصمين السابقين ابان الحرب البارده
وهو اتفاق قد يؤدي الى اثاره غضب الصين
ويعد التهميشا لدوري روسيا وفق ما نقلت
رويتنز التي اضافتها ان الصفقه التي قد
تكتمل خلال العام المقبل من شانها ان تحقق
الشراكه التي تم تطويرها في الاونه
الاخيره بين واشنطن ببيع اسطول من
المقاتله الامريكيه اف 16 في الوقت الذي
تواجه فيه الدوله الواقعه في جنوب شرق
توترات مع بكين في بحر الصين الجنوبي
المتنازع عليه الى السعوديه قال وزير
الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن فرحان ال سعود
من الامن في الشرق الاوسط يتطلب حلا عادلا
وشاملا للمشكله الفلسطينيه على اساس
القانون الدولي ومبادره السلام العربيه
فيما يضمن حق الشعب الفلسطيني في اقامه
دولته المستقله على حدود عام
1967 مشددا ان بلاده ترفض اي اجراءات
تعرقل حل القضيه الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]